and a warning this report does contain a
distressed baby with burns at the
beginning little jack is the exception
now he's an urgent case with burned feet
and hands which the emergency nurses are
wrapping in confirm he's not even one
year old but his mother is frantic with
worry and finding it difficult to calm
him she had no choice but to bring him
in to be honest that was not a man it
was just a limb very needed to be but
he's one of the very few casualties the
medics are having to deal with at
Warrington Hospital's emergency
department like many others they've seen
a drastic drop in people turning up
raising fears of a hidden number of
casualties too frightened to come in
because of fears over coronavirus what
I'm can I am very concerned about is
that patients are staying away in that I
don't believe that the heart attacks
have suddenly stopped happening I don't
believe that people aren't having
strokes
I'm concerning that people staying away
from coming to hospital because their
concerns about catching codes or being a
burden on the NHS the collateral damage
of kovat 19 can be seen here too the
only sound in entire hospital buildings
normally packed with patients and staff
is the clock ticking
this was an orthopedic surgery unit at
Holton General Hospital now sitting
empty the medics have been redeployed in
coronavirus treatment and all elective
operations canceled
look at this everything has been
mothballed this used to be a theater now
it's just a storeroom it gives you an
illustration of just how much has been
canceled and sacrificed because of
dealing with covert 19 these are the
brave ones those needing essential
treatment who are still coming in Valle
nura below with immune systems already
compromised there are worries that a
drop off in cancer screenings and
referrals means there are nearly 3,000
fewer people being diagnosed every week
according to cancer charities burns is
not one to be scared of his cancer
treatment but coronavirus has taken its
toll at 87 years old he's lived through
a world war and multiple epidemics
but Kovac 19 is his worst experience yet
like I say if you have to be in some
sort of hospital this is a sort of
hospital to be in
what are your worries generally about
coronavirus because we know that it
affects elderly people more I know that
my wife and I doing everything that we
can do our share of preventing the
spread of AIDS by isolating ourselves
but of course I miss my grandchildren as
well
sorry mrs. Edley sold the boat teenagers
because wife and I had been married a
little while before we found out what we
were doing wrong a rare bit of laughter
amid the tears called by coronavirus
Alex Crawford Sky News Cheshire